There's no denying just how much Netflix has
changed the game with its original series,
making marathon TV sessions and binge watching
completely normal.
But the streaming service's most ambitious
projects aren't without some mistakes, and
you know how much we love to point them out…
So we've singled out some of our favourites
to watch for during your next binge.
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Mistakes in Popular
Netflix Series.
Narcos
When you set a series or film in the 1970s
or 80s, you find out fast just how much technology
has changed in the decades since.
The lack of cell phones or gps is a plot point
in this look at Pablo Escobar's rise to power,
but some laughably modern gadgets made their
way into the show regardless.
When the main DEA Agent arrives in Colombia,
he has his passport scanned on a modern photocopier
- you can even spot the paper used to hide
the touchscreen.
A xerox machine at that time would have looked
more like a printing press, but it's the compact
satellite phones that put them to shame.
The worst offender: an Ericsson R290, which
wasn't released until the year 2000, more
than a decade ahead of the show's setting.
Jessica Jones
Marvel's alcoholic, superpowered private eye
is an expert at getting into and out of tight
spots, and finding a way past every locked
door.
But when Jessica heads into a hospital emergency
room, she needs to find a disguise to fit
in before getting what she's after.
But back up: the "authorized personnel only
sign was on OUR side of the door, meaning
she was leaving the department, not heading
in.
It makes sense if the show was filmed in a
working hospital, but the writing gives the
switch away.
Bloodline
The family drama and tension of this series
all begins when a troublemaking son returns
to his childhood home - with his big brother
there to greet him.
Except he doesn't arrive on the bus that he's
supposed to - or the one after it.
It's a sign of the headaches he'll cause in
the coming weeks, but loses a bit of its impact
when you realize the producers only filmed
one shot, with the exact same passengers stepping
off of back-to-back buses.
Maybe the show had even more hallucinations
than we thought?
Daredevil
It isn't until the sixth episode of this series
that the hero Matt Murdock squares off against
the Kingpin - and it's not even face to face.
The pair have a tense conversation over police
walkie-talkies, which should be harder than
it sounds.
Two-way radios like that mean they can either
talk or listen, but they'd have to take their
finger off the call button to even hear the
other end.
The sound effects pop in every once in a while,
but the two carry out the scene as if they're
talking on the phone.
Probably for the best, since one interruption
or rhetorical question would make the entire
scene fall apart... if it was actually done
right.
Orange is the New Black
Prison inmates can lose their cool at any
minute - a point proven when a secret cellphone
is discovered, sending the inmate using it
into a rage, taking her anger out on a washroom
stall door.
It's a intense moment, but the production
didn't want things to get TOO violent.
When the camera goes for a dramatic pan down
the stall, we can see the spring mounted on
the inside to keep the actual walls from getting
damage.
Either that, or a heavy metal spring and duct
tape are standard issue for women's prisons.
Daredevil
Not every mistake is so big, but even the
little ones are worth catching.
When Matt shares a latte with his local priest,
he takes it without sugar.
Probably because his super-hearing told him
that the sugar dispenser on the table was
only a prop.
The priest didn't get the memo, so the audience
had to watch as he tries but fails to pour
any out, only to give up once he realizes
the mistake.
House of Cards
Remember the good old days, when an angry
phone call could end with a slam, or a glass
of water thrown on a computer could result
in smoke and sparks?
Apparently the makers of House of Cards think
the same rules apply.
When one character is enraged at video footage
being shown on his laptop, he splashes his
drink, wrecking the monitor.
Except anyone who's ever spilled on their
laptop knows that's never the case in the
digital age.
The actor clearly matched the splash to the
video freezing - it's close, but still all
wrong.
Bloodline
The more serious a story, the funnier the
mistakes become.
Bloodline is filled with threatening characters
and scenes, but one is spoiled by a pretty
laughable mistake.
When a character is getting beaten for information,
his assailant drives the point home by pressing
the barrel of his gun into his skull.
Or, the barrel of his rubber gun, since it
can clearly be seen bending against the force.
Nobody caught it but the viewer so no harm,
no foul.
Orange is the New Black
Props are one thing, but we explained in a
previous video why giving major characters
visible tattoos can lead to some headaches
down the road.
The mistake is repeated, when Piper shows
a brightly-colored fish tattooed on the back
of her neck in the pilot episode.
The crew had clearly forgotten by season 2,
when the tattoo has magically vanished from
her neck completely.
Jessica Jones
The heroes and villains of the Avengers universe
may be no-shows in Marvel's Netflix series,
but Jessica Jones still lives in the same
Cinematic Universe.
Or does she?
When she heads to the top of Manhattan Bridge
to take in the city, Stark Tower, prominently
featured in The Avengers, is missing from
the skyline.
What audiences CAN spot is the MetLife building,
the skyscraper that Stark's eye-catching tower
should be sitting on top of.
It may just be a small effects mistake, but
shows that Marvel's Netflix and movie worlds
don't overlap as much as some fans hoped.
Those are some of the mistakes, errors, and
accidents we spotted in hit Netflix originals,
but which of your favourites did we miss?
Let us know in the comments for next time,
and remember to subscribe to our channel for
more videos like this one!